- Good evening, everybody.
I am very delighted to see you all
for joining for this exciting event.
I'm so glad to see so many of you
joining us tonight on Zoom.
We wish we could have been in person.
I'm here at the Yale Quantum Institute
on this very empty auditorium
but soon enough we'll have you over.
So for those who don't know
me, my name is Florian Carle.
I am the manager of the
Yale Quantum Institute
and the curator of the series
of non-technical talks,
co-sponsor by the Franke Program
for Science and the Humanities.
The goal of these event
is to bring a new rigor
on quantum physics and science in general
by having experts cast a new look
on an often overlooked
aspect of scientific work.
This is our 11th event
and this month mark the four
year anniversary of the series
that started in 2017.
During this four year,
we explore the variation of topics
from music to quantum
physics, math and crochet,
specs exploration and board
games, biology and cloning.
And tonight, we have the chance
to welcome the acclaimed
author and poet, Ben Okri,
for a special evening on
quantum physics and fiction.
Let me introduce the speaker for tonight.
So Ben Okri was born in Mina, Nigeria.
His childhood was divided between Nigeria,
where he saw firsthand the
consequences of war and London.
He won the Booker Prize in
1991 for "The Famished Roads"
and his novel, "The Astonishing the Gods",
was selected as BBC's 100
novel that shaped a world.
His work has been translated
into more than 25 languages
and he also write plays and screenplay.
He's a fellow of the Royal
Society of Literature
and has been awarded the
prestigious order of British Empire
as well as numerous international prices
and honorary doctorates.
He's tonight for...
He's presenting his newest
book, "Prayer For The Living",
which was released earlier
this month in the US.
I do have the UK version.
The US version has the cover
that you have behind me.
It's a collection of short story
that includes "Alternative
Realities Are True",
which he's gonna read tonight.
It's a strange investigation
of a murder in London
and you'll see very quickly
that it follows the strange
pattern of quantum physics.
So this event's gonna
be split in two parts.
Ben will read the story
and we'll have a slideshow
that goes along with it.
And then after the story,
we'll have a Q and A.
And without further
ado, please welcome Ben
and feel free to start whenever you want.
- Thanks, Florian.
It's a real pleasure to be there and here.
It's almost in itself, a quantum situation
that one is in two
places at the same time.
And tonight I'll be reading
"Alternative Relatives Are True"
which is set in London on various verses
or should I say universes, multiverses?
I must also add that it's a
real pleasure that you're here
and thank you very much.
Be great in the flesh,
but when all this is over,
let's hope we can manage it.
"Alternative Realities Are True".
It begins with a quotation.
"How wonderful that we
have met with a paradox.
Now we have some hope of making progress,"
Neos Bowl.
He woke one morning
into a strange universe.
Everything in his one
bedroom flat in Kensal Rise
was exactly the same
but everything was also
slightly different.
He was not sure how.
There was a message for him
on the answering machine
which he listened to with the irritation
the acute heat brought him.
He hadn't been able to sleep.
He'd been puzzling over his latest case.
With each new piece of information,
he was finding it more troubling.
The message was from the office,
delivered in a verbal encryption,
which he simultaneously deciphered.
The dead man had been seen
in the cafe at the canal.
He looked through the
crack in his curtains,
it was nearly dawn.
In his garden,
the black birds whistled
their morning chorals.
Usually, when he heard them,
he knew that sleep was over for him.
This morning, there
was something different
about their tone.
Detective Draper got out of bed
and slipped on his dressing gown
and went to his study to review the case.
On the face of it, the case was simple.
There had been a murder
near him in Kensal Rise
but the body of the
victim had not been found.
There was no actual proof of murder
but there was knowledge of it.
The young overwrought Muslim woman
in the blue hair dress,
who gave her name as Anna
had come into the local police station.
She had broken down and said
a man she knew had been murdered.
She gave his name.
When asked how she knew
he had been murdered,
her eyes widened and
she threw up her hands.
She knew, she said.
"Who was the murdered man?
Who was he to her?"
She was asked.
But she would not say.
"Who was the killer?"
She was asked.
At this, she panicked and
fled from the station.
A few inquiries led them to her address
and a watch was placed on the building.
A man by the name of Barrett,
the assistant of a famous artist
went missing that same day.
He had been known to
frequent the woman's flat.
This was a month ago.
Barrett had still not been found.
Detective Draper, who
believed more than anything,
that intuition was superior
to intellectual deduction,
opposing himself to the theatrical methods
of Sherlock Holmes,
which had so captivated the
police force, Scotland Yard
and the general public,
knew that he was dealing with a case
that amounted to more than
the appearance of the facts.
He believed that he was indeed...
He believed that it was indeed essential
to study a case thoroughly
to acquaint oneself with
the locale of the crime,
to handle the items of
the principle players.
In short, to furnish
the senses and instinct
with all the available data
and live in facts possible
and then like a fisherman
who must commit himself to the sea,
he must leave all those facts behind
and trust to the mysterious
dictates of intuition.
He had developed a faculty
of intuition as a young man
when he trained himself to be able to tell
on which side a coin would fall
just by following the
clearest whisper in his head.
By slow degrees, applying
this method to phone calls,
knocks on doors, letters
that he had received,
guessing their contents
and who had sent them
before opening them for verification.
He had come to develop
this mysterious faculty
to a formidable degree.
Detective Draper never
spoke about this to anybody
knowing full well, he would
be a laughing stock if he did.
He masters secret technique
behind a tremendous amount
of paperwork and planning
and detailed analysis.
To all accounts, from the outside,
he was an eminently practical
detective who did his research
and left nothing to chance.
In truth, he believed in the
fertility of chance itself,
which he did not regard as chance at all.
He believed that all things
in the universe were linked
and that every fact was
related to every other.
From his armchair, he solved
his cases by indirection.
He was the best in the force.
His reputation unmatched.
That morning in his study,
he went over the case methodically.
He realized that there was something wrong
with the facts of the case.
Some slight alteration of the world.
For example,
as soon as they put a watch
on the Muslim woman's house,
certain other facts of the case shifted.
This was puzzling.
The watch reported that
through the window,
he had seen Anna's neighbor,
a man named Jorg, cutting
up a large chicken.
The moment he noticed
the chicken being cut up,
the lights in Anna's room had come on.
Here was where it became baffling.
The watch swore that he saw
your both cutting up the chicken
and going into Anna's
room at the same time.
The watch was a sober man
of unimpeachable reputation.
There were several
other curious anomalies.
Another taken at random,
was that when Jorg was seen
cutting up a large chicken in his room,
the reported victim of the
murder was seen by witnesses
in a cafe on the canal, a
few miles down the road.
Those who saw him said
that he looked well,
if a bit anxious.
And that he was reading
a book at the time.
Most of the witnesses
could not recall the title of the book.
Detective Draper did not
think this at all unusual.
Most people he found did not notice
what was right under their noses.
The inattentiveness of people
was a constant source of amusement to him.
He had come to rely on their
failure to notice things.
His best deductions came
from working round the bends
of this failure.
Questioning one of the witnesses,
he was able, through indirection,
to work out the title of the book.
To any other detectives,
such a detail as a title of
a book a victim was reading
would be insignificant
but to detective Draper,
nothing in the universe was insignificant.
The witness, remembered in fact,
that the victim was reading a cat.
What do you mean he was reading a cat?
He was reading a cat.
Did he have an actual cat in his hand?
Both hands.
What color was the cat?
It did not have a color.
Did it have a name?
The last question had
come to detective Draper
purely by intuition.
It had simply dropped
into his mind like that.
But behind the intuition,
hovering like the ghost of knowledge,
was the understanding
that some people see words as real things
and that they are incapable
of the abstract faculty
of reading, transferring
everything they read
that has an image
straight away into its
physical equivalent.
This was one of those anomalous facts
that the detective
stored away in his mind.
Yes, it did have a name.
What was it?
It was a very strange name.
Before you tell me what it was,
tell me how you knew.
It's strange, but I just did.
I looked at the cat he was reading
and its name popped into
my head just like that.
"There is no need to tell
me the name of the cat,"
the detective said nonchalantly.
Why not?
I know it already, but thank you.
The detective rose to signify
the end of the interview,
leaving the witness quite baffled.
Detective Draper, upset minded,
the moment he was consumed by a clue,
called several bookshops.
In a short time,
he found out what he wanted to know.
A copy of the book had
been purchased that day,
quite early in the morning
from Any Amount Of Books
on Charing Cross Road.
It was the only copy of the
book purchased that morning.
A check confirmed that the
book had been bought by a Jorg,
as the detective had suspected.
Another call to the local police station
confirmed something else.
That the victim had not been seen since.
As it stood, there were two sightings.
One was of the suspected
killer in two places
at the same time.
The other was of the victim
after he had gone missing
and was presumed dead.
For the rest of the day,
contradictory reports kept pouring in.
A warrant for the arrest of
Jorg led to his detention.
The large chicken he
had been seen cutting up
was brought in as evidence.
But that same evening,
Jorg, who was in police custody,
was seen in Anna's room.
He was shouting at her at
one point called her a whore.
"I have killed that lover of yours
and there's nothing anyone
can do about it," he said.
"What have you done to him?"
She cried.
I have hidden him
where no one will ever
be able to find him.
She was heard wailing
and Jorg was seen departing from the room.
The watch was unable to do anything
because he had conclusive proof
that the murder suspect
was in police custody.
He had no legal right to
arrest the same person twice.
Detective Draper considered
the arrest of Jorg
to have been an act of sublime stupidity
by the local police.
The detective dropped
in at the local station.
The sergeant on duty, a fixed set man,
was reading "May Gray".
His name was Pillock.
And he had reputation for blue sickness.
"The way I see it, detective," he said,
"is that we know a
crime has been committed
but we have no evidence.
We suspect it's a murder,
but there is no body.
And he could be a potential terrorist.
We have to keep him locked
up for the public good."
The detective contemplated
Sergeant Pillock.
There was no use arguing with him.
Explanation was equally futile.
He would have to add the heavy
footedness of the sergeant
into the equation.
"But do you see that the problem
multiplies," Draper said.
I see that it simplifies.
Any new evidence?
Only CCTV footage on a bus.
What number?
Six, is that significant?
"Everything is significant," Draper said.
What did the footage yield?
Something puzzling.
What?
The suspect made several
trips in one direction
with black plastic bags.
He appeared to be moving house.
We never saw him get off.
Anything else?
Yes, but it doesn't make sense.
Tell me.
It stretches credibility.
Let's have it.
On one of the cameras,
we caught an image of the
bus just as it exploded.
Did it explode?
That's just it, it didn't.
We believe the CCTV system has been hacked
and false footage has been planted there.
Unless there is an
equally radical solution
but I fear we may be too late.
We have to act fast.
What shall we do?
The detective did a rapid calculation.
He felt himself uncircled by time.
The first thing he did
was order that the watch
be pulled off Anna's house.
Then he suggested that
the suspect to be released
and not followed.
Not followed?
No.
But he must be followed.
It will only make things worse.
How?
"We are being invaded by one
of many possible futures,"
Draper said.
What was that?
Nothing, forget it.
Are you on something?
No, I'm sober as a surgeon on duty.
Well then you need to fill me in.
Detective Draper knew he could
not explain the intuition
that was filtering through to him.
Weirdly, he sought the most
innocuous expression of it.
He softened his voice as he spoke.
Everything we do influences
what the suspect does.
We are multiplying the problem.
Before, there was one murderer.
Now, there are three.
Three?
Which three?
"Free," the detective corrected himself.
I meant he should be free.
Two.
Detective Draper knew
there were only two ways
to resolve the case.
One was to prevent the murder.
The other was to uncover it.
All the evidence suggested
it was too late to prevent the murder.
It had happened.
The past had now been lost.
If the victim had been apprehended
when he was seen reading the cat,
things might've been different.
That moment was gone.
It was lost because no one noticed
that the past lurks in the present.
Not just past events,
but the past as present.
Detective Draper liked to walk
after he had been immersed
in facts too long.
When he had spent all
day reading documents,
studying evidence, listening to witnesses,
when he was saturated
with too much information,
he would walk in a zigzag
path through side streets
to his home.
Anyone seeing him would think
he was wondering aimlessly
but his walks always followed
the pattern of his thoughts.
He had always known
that the indirect route
led more quickly to his destination.
The direct routes were often
bogged down in interruptions,
conversations and crowded streets.
That evening, after a
long spell at the station,
he left late.
His thoughts had gone off
the map of indirection.
He had taken so many side streets
that he did not recognize where he was.
He didn't mind.
His best intuitions came
while he was walking
and while waking.
Or rather, his best
intuitions came while waking
and while walking.
In an odd way, he seemed
to be doing both now.
He seemed to be waking from
the sleep of his thoughts.
Where was he?
He looked around.
He had gone off the main road
that led to his flat in Kensal Rise.
The street where he now stood
looked decidedly strange.
He searched for the street name
and found that he did
not even recognize that.
He walked on 'til he came to a barbershop.
There were no customers.
When he went in, he startled a barber
who was reading the newspaper.
"Can you please tell me where I am?"
The barber stared at
him with his mouth open.
"Is anything wrong?
You came in here about five
minutes ago," the barber said.
"And you asked the very same question."
Detective Draper looked around
at the clock on the wall
with its Roman numerals.
It was 6:35 p.m.
"So I did, so I did,"
detective Draper murmured.
And he hurried out.
He went back the way he had come.
A glance told him that the
barber had come out of his shop
and was watching him.
He walked faster.
Aware that the faster he walked,
the faster walked all the
events connected to him.
If he sped up, things would speed up too.
The web of connected events
responded to his every deed.
Suddenly, in his mind,
he could see the lines
that linked him to the victim
and the murderer and the woman.
Except that these lines had multiplied
in ways he could only guess that.
He was walking aimlessly now
following the vectors of his thoughts.
He conjectured that if he had arrived
at this strange place by getting lost,
then only by getting lost again
could he return to a familiar world.
He was thinking fast and walking fast
as if something unknown were stalking him.
The Lincoln lines moved
faster in his mind.
Then he suddenly stopped.
In the middle of all that wandering,
a clear thought distilled in pristine
dropped into his mind.
Why hadn't he thought of that before?
There was now only one
way to solve the murder.
The past was close to him.
There was only one path left.
He had to arrive at a future
place before the murderer did.
He had to outwit him in
all the vectors of time.
At this point, the murderer
had a time advantage over him.
He had to overturn that advantage.
He had to anticipate the
murderer in the future.
He walked home much more slowly.
He noticed the Kensal estates
and the silver birches
and the uneven pavement.
It did not surprise him that
he now knew where he was.
He walked slowly and breathed evenly.
As he turned into his street,
someone brushed past him.
The detective caught a confident smile
on the face of the man who adjusted him.
He was at his front gate when he realized
that the smile belonged
to the murder suspect.
But when he turned to
look, the man was gone.
There was an envelope
pinned to his front door.
Inside the envelope was a message
composed of letters cut out
of newspapers and magazines.
The message read,
all alternative realities are true.
The detective let himself into his flat,
shut the door behind him
and poured himself a glass
of Argentinian Altamira.
He sat down at a table near a window
to contemplate the letter.
After a while, he brought out
a one book of Escher drawings.
Leaving the door in his mind open,
he contemplated the drawings.
But in the other rooms in
his mind, he was thinking.
In his research, he had discovered
that the murder suspect
had an unusual interest
in a branch of speculative physics.
In one room in his mind,
he realized that the solution to the crime
was not to be found in the real world,
but in an unreal space,
a speculative realm.
In another room,
he pondered the message he had received.
All alternative realities are true.
He contemplated the
ramifications of the message
while leafing through the drawings.
Calmly, he began to chart out
the clear lines of the case.
Soon, he came to a dead end.
He paused and put down the book.
He knew that all dead ends are an illusion
designed to bring motion to a halt.
To those who can see beyond the illusion,
dead ends are portals into
unknown possibilities.
He paid more attention to dead
ends than to open highways.
He knew now that a leap
of faith was required.
Then he remembered the
cat that both men had.
Then he remembered the cat that
was both seen and not seen.
He realized he was going
to have to work backward.
He went to sleep that
night with the feeling
that he had at least stopped
the multiplication of the problem.
Part three.
The next morning,
an envelope was posted
through his letterbox.
Before he opened it,
he knew that he would find letters
cut out of newspapers and magazines
composing on elusive message.
The envelope contained a
single sheet of white paper
with the words, the world is still here.
He had a shower, got dressed,
regarded his face in the mirror.
The mirror had a slight warp that morning.
He was not sure that the
world was still there.
Outside, the weather had changed.
The sun shone intermittently
through the dark masses of clouds.
Cool wind with a deceptively
icy core, blew from the south.
He went down the side
streets towards the cafe
where the victim, Barrett,
had been seen reading a cat.
The cafe was run by a long-haired Italian
who combined obsequiousness
with a mildly intrusive personal charm.
Sitting in the same seat
where the victim had
been seen reading a cat,
detective Draper saw the
canal beyond the balcony.
There were boats mod on both sides.
The detective drunk his hot water slowly.
He had given up drinking coffee years ago
and now settled for the digestive
refinements of hot water.
Outside, birds were
wheeling over the canal.
While sipping, he had a singular thought.
He knew that entertaining
it would create realities
that would only blur the case further.
So he pushed the thought
to a corner of his mind.
He caught a taxi back to the office.
To test his theory,
he had his contact at the
Evening Standard plan to report
that the police were draining
an obscure canal in Richmond
in their search for the missing body.
To lens this deception the
veneer of plausibility,
he had two amateur frogmen
busily explore the canal.
They were to pretend to pull something out
of its shallow depths.
"What's the idea behind
this flagrant waste
of public funds on sham
frogmen in a remote canal?"
Asked his superintendent, who
had summoned him to lunch.
"You are aware that I
have gone out on a limb
for you too many times and I've
never let you down, have I?"
Detective Draper replied,
calmly buttering in his roll.
"No you haven't, I grant that,
but there are many people after your job.
They will use anything to get at you.
God knows you have enough
disadvantages as it is."
"Do I?"
Detective Draper said while
the glimmer of a new thought
filtered through a door in his mind.
You know you do, you're
not an Oxbridge man.
Neither are you.
You are black.
I wasn't going to say
that, but you thought it.
Look, we run the most color
blind department in the country.
You took the words right out of my mouth
but I'm the only one that is...
We have to face the
realities of the world.
Detective Draper suddenly stiffened.
He held his head at an angle.
A new thought had come through.
"Do we?"
He said absentmindedly.
"Yes, we do," replied the superintendent,
puzzled by Draper's behavior.
Have you had this
conversation with me before?
That's what I was getting to.
About an hour ago?
Yes, why?
We don't have any time,
we have to stop it now.
Stop what?
There will be another
murder unless we act fast.
Murder?
Of who?
The woman, she'll be murdered
and there'll be no evidence of it.
Why not?
Because she would have
been murdered yesterday.
Detective Draper stood up.
"You're not making sense, man,"
the superintendent exploded.
"Sit down and explain yourself."
I really must dash, sir.
I'll have a full explanation
for you tomorrow afternoon,
if all goes well.
"But tomorrow is Saturday,"
the superintendent said
to the departing figure of the detective.
Yorkshire are playing
Middlesex at the oval.
"I know," Draper said
before he disappeared through the door.
"And the score will be 17 to one."
"What?"
Cried the superintendent.
Detective Draper was
already out on the street.
Part four.
From the Kensal Rise police station,
detective Draper
requisitioned three frogmen.
Early on Saturday morning,
he had them dive into the
canal at Little Venice,
right near the cafe.
The area was cordoned off.
The frogmen in their dark wetsuits
began their mysterious exploration.
There was a unit of police there
with an unmistakable police van.
Detective Draper watched from a distance.
If his intuition was correct,
in the next hour a number
of things would happen.
Their precise order interested him.
He knew he was in the realm
of a speculative space now
where actually seen what was sought
made his existence real.
The time, the opportunity were limited.
Things were in mutant formation.
Events were hovering between two realms,
between being and non being.
From here on, the
operation will be delicate.
The frogmen in the obscure
canal at Richmond found nothing
as was the intention.
But the story planted in
the "Evening Standard"
had this desired effect, as far
as the detective could tell.
He kept looking at his watch.
The frogmen here, at
the Little Venice canal,
took turns in going in.
One of them would stand
on the edge of the canal
and then flip over backwards.
He would route around below
for awhile and then emerge.
For an hour now, they had been exploring
and had found nothing.
The cricket game had began at the Oval.
The heat was beginning to rise.
It was a bright day and
people had begun to stop
to watch the strange
proceedings on the canal.
This too had been factored
into detective Draper's
complex calculation of events.
Only by the frogmen dive in,
verifying and bringing up,
could there be anything to
dive for, verify and bring up.
The detective knew this.
Something will be found
only because something is looked for.
The looking creates the finding.
In just the same way,
only the presence of
onlookers created the event.
They onlookers were essential.
The detective had surmised
that what was needed
was a waiting of events,
a way in of events toward
a more dense reality
to counter balance the
ambiguous reality between worlds
which had so far bedeviled
the investigation.
He intuited that all worlds
had to come together here.
That was why even before
he had full permission,
he'd arranged for the frogmen
to make a public exhibition
of excavating the muddy
depths of the canal.
The ruse had worked.
The item planted in the "Evening Standard"
had caught the lively
interest of Londoners.
And soon everyone was talking about it.
The crowd around the canal,
observing the frogmen,
grew in number.
The trap sprung had yielded
multidimensional fruits.
An off-duty policemen had
spotted the suspected murderer
near the Little Venice canal
and had reported the matter
to the local police station.
The station chief had relayed the message
to detective Draper.
With a nonchalant expression,
he continued to observe
the frogmen at work.
Twice, the frogmen claimed
to have found nothing.
They had said it was just
mud and rotten bicycles
and broken puddles down there.
The detective,
with his keen awareness
of the power of numbers,
said twice does not make
anything conclusive.
The canal could seal secrets
which must be exposed.
My career depends on it.
Maybe even my life.
He sent the frogmen down a third time.
He suggested that they look
not so much in the deeper parts
but in the parts no one
would think of looking.
"What part is that, sir?"
One of the frogman said.
You will know when you find it.
Disgruntled, they returned to work.
They flipped over backwards
and disappeared beneath
the muddied surface.
Detective Draper, aware of
the proximity of the murderer,
knew that it was now a race against time.
The frogmen had to find something
before the murderer found him.
He remained calm.
He ordered a cup of hot
water from the cafe.
The cafe manager, Vin Insusient, Italian,
brought the water himself.
His de-shoveled locks
fell across his face.
The Italian handed the
detective the cup of hot water
and held onto the pot.
"So what is going on, sir?"
The cafe manager asked.
Detective Draper turns to look at him.
The Italian had the eyes of an insomniac.
It's best if you don't know.
We don't want you entangled
in the more fatal webs of the problem.
I might be able to help.
How?
I hear things.
People tell me things.
I'm sure that's true.
I'll contact you if your help is required.
"Anytime," said the Italian.
"It would be an honor to be of service."
The cafe manager stood there
watching the first frogman
emerge from the mucky canal.
The detective turns to
him with a furrowed brow
and the Italian immediately understood
that his presence had become redundant.
He filled the detectives cup
and retreated into his cafe.
Detective Draper felt the
murderer moving closer.
But he sipped his hot
water with perfect calm.
"It's not the number of encounters
in the numberless realms that counts,
it is the world in which
the encounter is fixed,"
thought the detective, grimly.
A flurry among the fragments told him
that the nature of the
game had shifted at last.
He drunk water was left of his hot water
and went toward them.
One of the frogmen had pulled out,
from the depths of the
canal, a black plastic bag.
Dripping with muck, it
was placed on the ground.
The frogman hosed it down
and then the detective had it brought
to the back of the van.
A casual glance at his form
told him what he needed to know.
There was no need to expose the contents.
The first stage of the
duel had been fought.
It might've been difficult
to fix the reality of
this black dustbin bag
but now that it was fixed,
the rest was sure to be found.
It was at that moment,
perhaps delayed by the variable factors
in the calculations of time,
that a shadow moved into site.
Jorg fired two shots.
One pierced the metal of the white van,
the other grazed detective
Draper's shoulder.
Then Jorg was wrestled to the ground
by the plainclothes policemen
who had been drinking cups
of innocuous tea in the cafe.
Before the detective fell,
he was heard to cry out,
"on no account are the frogmen
to seize the exploration."
He passed out for only a few moments.
An act of will wrenched him
back into consciousness.
Detective Draper allowed the paramedics
to bandage his shoulder
while he surveyed the scene before him.
The frogmen had persisted
and eventually they had dredged
up three black bin liners
from diverse parts of the canal.
They were hosed down and
kept in the back of the van
where the bullet had pierced.
The detective had no need
to inspect their contents.
He knew what they were.
The afternoon sun played
on the water of the canal
making its surface shine like gun metal.
The light came through the trees
on both sides of the metal fences.
Detective Draper could see
the church through the leaves.
He felt tired.
He made a signal to one of the men.
They bore him into a waiting car,
but instead of being taken to the hospital
for further treatment,
he insisted on being taken home.
Section five.
The next morning, with his arm in a sling,
detective Draper was
at the police station.
Out of respect for the part
he had played in the investigation,
he was allowed the first conference
with the man who had shot him.
They were in a soundproof room.
The detective sat on a chair at the table
and the murderer sat opposite.
"Something puzzles me," said Jorg.
There was nothing repentant
about his expression.
He stared at the detective intensely.
You want to know how I knew where to look.
Jorg smiled.
It was a thin smile
sustained by something
resembling a twitch.
Then he nodded faintly.
"My question to you," said Draper.
"Is why?"
Why what?
They were still dueling.
It was not over yet.
There was still the chance
of further multiplications.
He had to be careful.
Why did you kill him?
Are you sure it is why and not when?
I know when.
You do?
You're not going to trap
me that easily again.
I have no idea what you mean.
"Of course you do," said Draper.
All alternative realities are true.
"I see," said Jorg.
"You got the clue.
It was designed to throw me off the scent.
You went against your on
psychology," said Jorg.
"Like you, I have many psychologies,"
the detective said leaning back.
But why did you kill him?
He was after my woman.
She was not your woman.
She told the police that
you were just her neighbor
and that you misunderstood her friendship.
She was a whore and he deserved to die.
He was not even one of us.
You killed him out of jealousy.
Not jealousy, revenge.
The detective stood up.
He felt weary.
He was at the door when Jorg
fired the last question at him.
How did you know?
The detective at that moment
felt a throb of pain in his shoulder.
"The world is still here," he replied.
He went out.
Section six.
Three hours later, he was
sitting with the superintendent
in the Scotland Yard canteen.
They had window seats
looking out over the river.
The facts don't make sense.
Can you make sense of them for me
so I can explain it to the board?
I don't recommend an explanation.
What then?
Leave them with the facts.
Sometimes people need to
be brought face-to-face
with the incomprehensibility of the world.
The superintendent stared at him.
"Now you know why you will
never make department head,"
he said.
It was never my ambition.
You have ambitions?
"I have ambitions that
perhaps you won't understand,"
said the detective sipping his hot water.
Besides, there are things
better than ambition.
How can you stand to drink
that tasteless stuff?
"It's not tasteless at all," Draper said.
"It restores me to the fundamental
simplicity of the world."
The world seems to be anything but simple.
Take this case for example,
what on earth was going on?
It wouldn't make sense if I explained it.
Try me.
It was a multiverse murder.
What on earth is that?
Speak plain English, man.
It was a murder that
happened in many universes.
You must be mad.
In one universe, the
murder hadn't happened yet.
In another, it had.
Each time we apprehended
him, we multiplied...
Okay, that's enough of that.
If I hear anymore,
I might start to have
crackpot ideas myself.
Just telling me this, why the canal?
I realized it when I learned
the victim was seen in
the cafe reading a cat.
Reading a cat?
The policeman who saw him was dyslexic.
His condition was extreme.
He saw virtually what he read.
About 1% of dyslexics have this syndrome.
What was the cat he was reading?
It was a book.
The book gave me the second clue.
The rest unraveled itself.
Out with it, man.
You're tying me up in riddles.
What was the book?
"Schrodinger's Cat".
Schrodinger's what?
He had bought the book that morning
and was seen reading it in the cafe
after he had been murdered.
Unless we are dealing with operations,
there could be only one solution.
The superintendent looked
red faced and exasperated.
I had to somehow get all the universes
in which the murder was
multiplying to converge.
I had to create what physicist
called an event convergence.
"What on earth is that?"
Bellowed the superintendent,
by now a swollen image of himself.
It is the one event, the one
thing that will fix time.
In quantum mechanics, it is conjecture
that the universe only
comes into existence
when we perceive it.
I surmise that perhaps
the body of the victim
would only be found when we find it.
The crime did not exist
'til the body was found.
And the body was in the bin bags?
Exactly.
How did you know?
One of the watchers
outside the woman's house
had seen the murder
suspect cutting a chicken.
It was a chicken.
It was a chicken because the
watcher had seen a chicken.
Do you mean to say...
Yes.
The superintendent
paused for a long moment.
But why was he trying to kill you?
He wasn't really, we have to understand
that this man was taking a cosmic gamble.
He never really had any
intention of killing anybody.
He was overcome with rage, with jealousy,
with a kind of love madness.
In that state it occurred to him
that maybe if he killed
the man in one universe,
the man would still be alive in another.
Somewhere along the line,
he forgot what university was in.
In short, he lost his reason.
You mean he went mad?
It depends on what you think madness is.
Continue.
In one of those universes,
it's occurred to him
that if he could stop me
before I could find the body,
then he would never be caught
and the murder will, to all accounts,
be forever speculative.
Why wasn't I told all this at the time?
You were at your cricket match, sir.
A terrible game, we were mauled.
Sorry to hear that, sir.
Still, you could have sent a message.
It was a delicate matter.
What does that mean?
I had to arrive at the body
before the bullets arrived in me.
There was a long pause.
"Detective Draper, you look terrible,"
the superintendent said.
"When was the last time you had some sun?"
Can't remember, sir.
Get some sun.
I want that shoulder
working when you get back.
Take a holiday, detective Draper.
"Thank you, sir," the detective
said with a wry smile.
"I think I might while
the world is still here."
- That was a fantastic story.
Thank you so much for taking
the time to read it to us.
- It was a pleasure.
It's a pleasure.
Much more fun than I feared it would be.
- We're having a bunch
of people in the Q and A,
setting pressing question and things,
but the first thing that I want to ask you
is that there's very few literary works
about quantum physics.
The one that comes in mind
is the Michael Fray's play, "Copenhagen"
that staged the discussion
between Neil Bors,
which you used as an
epigraph for your story
and Heisenberg and his wife, Norland.
But murder in quantum physics
is kind of a unique mix.
Like, can you tell us a little bit
why you choose quantum
physics to stage this murder
and how did the story come together?
Or like, what was your process?
- Well, it's very hard to talk of process
with a story like this.
I don't know if I should tell
you how the story came about,
it might actually spoil the
wonderful mystery of it.
Let's just say very simply,
that I was put in a position
where I had to write a story,
a detective story.
And I've read so many detective stories
and I thought to myself,
I really don't know how I can add anything
to this really famous genre.
And at the same time, for some time,
in fact, for a long time,
I've been having a very secret
interest in quantum physics
and quantum mechanics
and I've been reading
around the edges of it
for all sorts of reasons,
partly because of
fascination with this field
and this subject
because it's one of the
few fields in science
that for the first time
actually begins to
undermine the certainties
that we have about reality.
And also one of the fields in science
that for the first time begins to hint
at kind of a spectral unseen
and fascinating dimension
to existence and to the
world as we think we know it.
It's in fact, it's an era that
really troubles the surface
of our set certainties.
And I found that really,
really, really magnetic.
So I thought to myself,
wouldn't it be wonderful
if I brought a great secret
love with a public problem?
I have to write a detective story
and wouldn't it be great
if I brought the two things together?
So I conceive of the
idea of detective Draper
and the heart of the case
would be an issue
concerning quantum physics,
quantum mechanics.
The uncertainty of the world,
the way in which that which
we look at changes by looking
and the idea of superpositions
and various things like that.
And at the same time, I
wanted to write the story
in such a way that the
story itself was symbolic
of the quantum universe
or at least a way in which things act
as far as we know on that level.
And I was just fascinated by
this abstruse, this obscure,
this challenge, this difficult problem.
And it was that more than anything.
But also I think the
thing that fascinated me
was it was the relationship
between writing itself
and the quantum world.
I find there's a great resonance
between the two things.
So you have to understand, Florian,
that as a child,
one of the first things I
wanted to be was a scientist.
I wanted to be a physicist.
If I'd known, when I was a kid,
that there was such a thing
as speculative physics,
you wouldn't be talking to me now.
I'd be where you are.
Where you are.
- (laughs) That's wonderful.
It's interesting because
I had the opposite things.
I was doing theater before
and then switched midway
to become a scientist.
So maybe that's what we are.
We are just opposites.
We switched at the same time (laughs).
I have another question for you.
You use real places to anchor your story.
And we talked about,
when I proposed to you to read the story,
you're like, "oh! it would be great
to have some way to like
not have the audience
just watch me read."
And I was like, what can I do?
And I started looking at maps of London
and I starting to see
that I could actually
pinpoint all the details,
like all the places that
you mentioned in the book,
the bookshop, the Kenal,
the police station,
all the streets are real and they exist.
And like, can you tell us why
you picked like a real place?
Is it because you were worried
that if you have like a weird
location plus quantum physics
that would be too much for the reader?
Or you were like,
"oh! This is the place
that I like, that I know
and I can create something
that can have multiple varieties on this."
- All of the above, actually.
I think one of the great
secret laws of writing,
which is that the real is
underpinned by the unreal
and the unreal is supported by the real.
These two things kind of
work together invisibly
in just the same way
that the quantum world
and what we perceive of as
the world of certainties
operate at the same time.
One is concealed or as it were
exists deep inside the other.
So one needs the reality.
I find that to investigate
on reality, you need reality
to really look deeply into a problem.
The more truthful the place
is, the more real the place is,
the easier it is for you
to actually plunge into your exploration.
- Yeah, that's wonderful.
I'm gonna start reading
through the question
that the audience is putting
on the Q and A panel.
We have a first question
which is maybe more common recommended
from Michelle Doberay,
who's one of the quantum
physicists that we have at YQI.
He says fantastic quantum story
and something is puzzling him.
Is the story built
around the picture of
a fragment in the Kenal
or is it the opposite?
And the reason why I'm putting this
is because it's a funny comment
that Michelle is really well known.
That to name all of these
quantum objects after animals.
So we had, of course the cats,
but there's a snail happening.
There's also some squid and
so I wouldn't be worried,
I wouldn't be surprised
that in the near future,
one of the quantum
devices had a frog somehow
linked into this.
(all laughing)
I will keep an eye on
that, I'll let you know
and maybe you should
take some of the credit
if we see a quantum computer
with a frog (indistinct).
(laughs) We have another question
from somebody that you
probably know, Priya Nafarajan,
who's the director of the Frankie Program
and she said, "I love
the layers of reality
that you explore in this story.
Just curious, do you believe
that narratives are stable
or are you playing with
this notion as well?"
- Yeah, all wonderful questions.
Again, narrative,
the relationship between
reality and the quantum world,
narrative, while you're
reading it, the arc of it
while you're emersed in
it and reading the words
and following the story
and the characters and
the plot, appear stable.
When you finished reading
it and you've left the text,
the inherent stability
narrative then begins to act
on memory, mind, emotion,
nostalgia, replay
and all of that.
Then you go back to the text again
and then something strange happens.
What was fixed and familiar
and certain and definite
undergoes occasionally
wobbles and wrinkles.
It changes.
You finished again with this new change
and then you go back
and you live your life
and then you come back to the text again.
And the same thing has happened.
So is narrative stable?
Is it unstable?
It's impossible to say.
It's the same.
This is what I'm trying to say.
That the literature, that writing,
shares something of the quantum universe,
it really, really does.
Because when you have it in front of you,
you take a famous line that
like to be or not to be,
you have it in front of you.
It is absolutely fixed just
like this chair or this table
as I'm looking at.
But you come back to
it, you break it down,
you look into it, you move away from it,
you carry it around in your spirit,
you come back to it another time
and something about it has shifted,
something about it has altered.
And I think narrative plays and
works with our consciousness
in the same way that the reality
of reality works on warps
and changes and shifts
with our consciousness.
I think the two things are linked.
I didn't choose the quantum
universe arbitrarily
in the writing of the story.
It's also meant to be a parallel
of the way in which literature,
the way in which words,
letters, punctuation,
these little quantum tools
as it were work on the mind
and on consciousness.
- Thank you very much.
Another question I have is
that "Prayer For The Living",
your new book, is a very political book.
Yeah, you have the new
version, even better.
Here we go.
I will put in the chat.
So I think you will have,
in the invitation from Zoom,
you have the link.
If you wish to buy the book,
you should be able to do it
through different online sellers.
So feel free to grab a copy of it.
All the stories are really wonderful
and I highly recommend this book.
It's pretty good.
And so-
- Thank you, Florian.
- It seems to be the less
subversive than for example,
if we can run them the
first story, "Boko Haram",
about a suicide bomber child
and still in this murder mystery,
which seems very operatical,
you explore some racial tension
in the police departments
between the detective Draper
and the superintendent.
And it's a very shocking thing
because there's been a lot of discussion
about race and racial prejudices
and systematic racism.
And even the story when the
reader is focusing on the loops
and like all the clues
and all the details,
you bring them back into reality
and realize that even in
this alternate reality
is you have the same flow and prejudices.
I find it like an
incredibly effective tool,
like narrative tool to
like really bring it back.
Like, is it something that
you thought in events like,
oh! This is a way,
or did it came more organically say like,
because this is what usually happens
in this kind of a structure?
- Yes, well, it came organically
because I wanted you, first of
all, to follow this detective
purely from a point of
view of the tradition.
The tradition of detectives
like Sherlock Holmes,
like Lupin that's
suddenly become famous now
because of the Netflix series.
I want you to follow, first of all,
enter into a genre identification
with detective Draper
and to enter this world,
enter the exploration with him
just purely on that basis.
On the pleasure of that tradition.
But at some point,
I wanted to pull the reader up short
with the unstated reality.
I'm fascinated by unstated
realities in reading,
'cause I think we're overwhelmed
by stated realities enough
to a point we stop seeing them,
we stop noticing the
depth of certain problems,
the depth of certain realities.
We stop noticing them
because we acquire kind
of object blindness
from too much familiarity
and too much ease
and too much superficial
saturation in a sense.
And I wanted to drain
the story of all of that.
I'm free to experience that fact
which was there all along
towards the end of the story
or in the middle of it.
Just to sprinkle it
and then come back out.
Because I think sometimes
when you invert things,
they're stronger.
It's just a new way
of dealing with one of the
facts of a rich universe.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
It's a lovely tough question.
- Yeah, I know (laughs).
We have some more question in the chat.
Somebody said that I was curious
about the reference to the bus explosion
and the murderer potentially
being a terrorist.
Are there social political intent
in introducing these elements
in light of the story being written
through the eyes of a police officer
trying to make sense of ambiguous events
enfolding in the London older class?
- Yes, absolutely.
I wanted these political
realities to be there
within what seems to be a genre fiction
that is complicated by quantum mechanics.
I love the idea of having these realities.
They're also in London where I live,
near parts of Kensal Rise.
There's been a lot of those
kinds of tensions there.
I mean, the story has to
use a garden as terms,
healthy roots.
It's still rooted in real things
that have given a more
mysterious expression.
So I want it to be true
to a reality that I knew
even while writing this,
what seems like a piece of genre fiction.
- [Florian] Thank you.
- I like evaded realities.
I like creating worlds where the real,
where the realities of the world
in which we're living in
invades it and seeps into it,
As well as doing the opposite,
which is looking head on, as you said,
with the Boko Haram stories.
I like looking head on at things
in a very steady, intense way
but also like the indirect leaking in.
- I have another question
more general about the book.
It's a collection of short story
that I know you've collected
for all your career.
Sorry, yeah (laughs).
I should stop.
- I like it, I like it.
We have to keep alternating.
- (laughs) It's an alternate
reality, is I have something.
Also speaking of alternate realities,
I had a question because
this, in the lecture,
the chapter, the part five is missing.
And so I was wondering if it was like...
In my head I was like,
oh! Maybe it's like a chapter somewhere
that is hidden somewhere in the book.
And I just realized when you read it,
I had this like realization
at the same time
that inspector Draper was
unraveling the mystery.
I was like, oh! I'm unraveling
the mystery of my copy.
It just (indistinct).
(all laughing)
So yeah, in this collection of series,
how did you pick and arrange the order?
And I knew that short story
I consider the hardest form
of literature to write.
For you, what was the advantage
of using these formats?
- You mean the short story format
or the way in which it was arranged?
- Yeah, yeah.
Why did you pick to do a
collection of short stories
and instead of maybe
you could have expanded
some of the other story that you had
into like a full-fledged novel?
Like, what is the advantage
of having this format?
- Oh! Florian, Florian,
the whole point of the
truth of a short story...
Well, a lot of writers tend to think
that the short story is really
a frustrated short novel
or rather a stunted novel
or a novel that just didn't
get a chance to grow.
Hadn't had its vitamins and its protein.
No, that's not the case,
that's not the case at all.
If a short story can
be expanded to a novel,
then it never was a short
story in the first place.
It's just that you didn't realize it.
And we have to remember
that people like Joyce,
"Ulysses" was meant to be
one of the last short stories
in "Dubliners".
And it just grew and it
was never a short story.
You can't expand a short
story into a novel.
That's the nature of the short story.
It is completely...
It has a complete integrity
of its compactness.
The complete integrity of the fact
that it cannot be made more than it is.
It's perfect and complete length
and it's not really about the length.
It is about the tensions
contained within it.
It's about actually,
forgive the phrase Florian,
It really is about is quantum...
Is quantum universe, the
inner spaces, the core,
the electrons, the
things working inside it,
the way they work and
play with one another
in a tremendously secret
inner world dynamism.
The short story is really a world.
It's not a compressed world.
It's a complete world.
It might appear that
you've taken a slice of it
but the laws that make it are complete.
And I love the short story form as a...
For me, it's one of the best
forms explore certain thoughts,
experiments, certain
questions, certain challenges,
certain themes, certain obsessions.
It's more than a laser.
It's more than a laser,
more than an x-ray.
It's a new kind of a very
high powered super lens
that looks really deep into
the nature of a problem
and that is able to distill it into this.
I think it's a miraculous form
and that's why I've done so few of them
because it takes such a long time to craft
so that they have this extraordinary,
strange living tension.
- Okay, thank you very much.
Maybe we can take one last question
and then-
- Oh! Be generous, Florian.
- Oh! Okay (laughs).
We'll see.
You've heard Ben, if
you have more questions,
feel free to add them-
- Yeah, take two or three more.
- (laughs) Will do.
So we have someone who who's writing that,
thank you, I was fascinated by your work
and I am currently writing
my bachelor dissertation
on the "Famish Roads" and Unjoki's novel,
"Transparent City".
I am wondering if you know
of the concept of Ubunthu
and if you think that this
or commonly in general,
is one of the steps that
leads to a better world
or do you think
that urbanization,
globalization and capitalism
have a negative impact on communities?
At least the small one,
such as the compounds
and then obstruct potential
growth and experiences.
- Oh my goodness!
That question is as far
from the quantum universe
as you can possibly get.
But then at the same time, it isn't
because I mean, Ubuntu
is in how the philosophy
of a quantum universe affects
and shapes a whole world.
Yeah, I think Ubuntu is a
very great African concept
that can have very great
important consequences
for the world.
It's a philosophy that should
be made more widely known.
It's a philosophy of
compassion, of community,
of harmony and yeah, I
love the sound of it.
And what was the question
about globalization?
Has it had an impact on communities?
- Yes.
Especially the smaller ones.
If you want, you can also open the panel.
It's a long question then.
So you should be able to see it.
It's the first one on the top.
- Yeah, I'm going to.
I'm not going to get drawn into that.
That would be too complicated for me.
(all laughing)
To get into the whole, yeah.
To give a very short answer,
yes, globalization has
had a negative impact
on smaller communities.
It's one of the difficult
things to deal with.
How to keep the richness
of small communities
within the impact of globalization.
And yet at the same time,
globalization is one of
the facts of our world.
I'm a great believer in
not wishing away a fact.
A fact is something we have to deal with,
negotiate, fight, neutralize, work with,
do something about, but
we have to face them.
It's what we writers do.
We're not good at running away from facts.
We look at them and give them an image.
And the impact of
globalization can be seen
in quite a few of the
stories in this collection.
- Thank you.
On that topic of African beliefs,
we have another question of like,
how do the African spiritual beliefs
with the fluidity
between the natural world
and the spiritual realm
influence the story?
Or do they?
- I'm not sure that they do
except to the degree that maybe
my mind is already saturated
with certain beliefs that
I grew up with in Nigeria.
Not just a belief,
but this sense that the
boundaries between realms
is more fluid than we think.
Maybe that already predisposed
me to be interested
in the quantum universe
where the invasion,
where suddenly reality
is for the first time
in a scientific context under great doubt
and great scrutiny, great uncertainty.
The other thing I want to add
quite separate from that, Florian,
about my fascination
with quantum mechanics
is the place of
consciousness in all of this.
And of course, this is something
that quantum physicists are not...
I don't know how you deal with it.
You deal with the external aspect
of the effect of measurement,
the effect of measurement
on or the effect of looking,
of witnessing, of observing
on the actual process,
the split experiments, for example.
But I am fascinated in what
it is about consciousness,
about the conscious, the
fact of the consciousness
of the observer that actually
gives rise to this effect,
that actually gives rise to the
fixing of these subparticles
into either a wave or a particle.
I'm fascinated by this side
of the quantum equation, us
and our consciousness and how it...
What is going on here that
affects what's going on,
if you can say, there?
Can I ask you,
is it something that is dealt with at all
within the quantum institute?
Is this something that you guys look at?
- It's something like the observer effect,
is something that of course
is really well-known here
and then that they try to fight
but I don't think there's a more like,
there's a more philosophical
research of that
like in the world
because in the day-to-day
life of a researcher,
they perform experiments
and the way they deal
with this observer effect
is that they use sights techniques
to like measure indirectly
the measurements
and perform calculation in an indirect way
to avoid, per tube, the result
and the inside of the experiments.
And so I don't think
people are really thinking
about how themself affect the results.
I think they more are looking for ways
to prevent that from happening
and obtaining the right answer.
However, that's something that
the Yellow Quantum Institute
has been trying to investigate
by hiring artists in residence.
We had a few people coming in
and trying to think about these topics
and that's something that
I don't think a researcher,
like who are trying to build
a quantum computer currently
have time to think about that.
There's a huge race in
the US and the world
to build the first quantum computers
and I think it's gonna be
another pan of the research
or of maybe having people from
the humanities and philosophy
trying to think about these topics.
And I think bringing in artists
that might be able to
use a different technique
or different medium to
sort of open a reflection
is something that we've done.
For example, in this space
that's in front of me,
we used to have a big quantum computer.
And like, it was an art
piece done by Martha Lewis
that had cameras and sensor.
And when the visitor will
go inside this installation,
the visitor was perturbing
the calculation that was done
with lights and sensor.
And so it was interesting to see
that the art piece was working perfectly,
performing a very simple
quantum computation
but it was working without anybody in it.
And as soon as a visitor enter the space,
the camera will pick it up
and then will sort of like
disturb the calculation
and you couldn't really do
the calculation anymore.
And so there was a way to see ourselves
disturbing the quantum world in a sense.
So of course, everything was at quantum
because there was at a
scale, at the human scale
and it was doing in classical computers.
But we were trying to start
and to create this tiny
idea in people's heads
to start thinking about these topics.
- Interesting.
We have to have more
of these conversations.
I think science needs
to take an interest...
At some point in the future,
we're gonna have to deal with
the science of consciousness.
At some point.
Maybe in 1,000 years time
but we're gonna have to deal with it.
- And if it's a bit shorter
timeframe than that,
maybe there will be a good excuse
to have you come to the YQI.
(all laughing)
But if it's far on you as well,
we'll have to wait on that.
- I might still be around, who knows?
(all laughing)
We'll decompose time, slow time down.
- That's better.
- [Ben] Any other questions before I go?
- Let me have a quick look in the chats.
Yes, we have one last question
which is on the topic of short story.
Who do you admire as master of
the art from past or present?
Is there any modern day practitioner
that excites you on this?
So it's a more general on
the theme of short story.
- Oh my goodness!
- I guess what they want is
like maybe some recommendation,
some good read recommendation
on short story (laughs).
- Yeah, I'm very old fashioned
and I mean, I read a
lot of new short stories
but I go back to the old ones
for the reasons I mentioned earlier
because the thing about
a great short story,
the thing about the great novel,
the thing about a great poem,
a great piece of writing,
is that it multiplies its realities.
It really does.
Not only is it not the same
every time you read it,
it gets incredibly richer.
It gets immeasurably richer.
And I think we bring that
constant richness to it.
But in order for that to happen,
there is one condition for that to happen
which is that the piece
itself has to have acquired,
have had to have begun, first of all,
with the condition of a very
high level of achievement,
of accomplishment, of compression,
of truth, of integrity.
Call it greatness, call
or whatever you want.
It has to have had that first
and then that has to
have interacted and moved
and played and danced and
be shaped and shaped in
and time itself and
consciousness and many readers
and so a text is enriched
by the vast number of secret
readings brought to it
or to them.
And so I tend to go back to
the reading enriched texts,
texts that have played and
worked and dreamt through time.
So I love some of the
Savantas short stories
and here's another very
interesting one, "Donkey Shooter",
a book that's almost 1,000 pages long.
It began as a short story,
that tells you something
about the way in which the
short can contain the vast
and the vast can contain the small.
I check over, I keep going back
to the many wonderful modern masters.
Many of them can be read in
the pages of the "New York"
and magazines and
anthologists around the world.
There are many young and
excellent African writers.
It's not hard to find really,
really good short stories
but if you want to deep
travel on a deep journey,
well, you could go to the ones
that have acquired their presence in time.
Go to people like Chekov, yes.
More personal, yeah.
- Thank you so much, Ben.
Maybe we can conclude on that
by doing some entanglement experiments.
When I can show the UK
version of your book
and you can show us the
US version of your book.
So, yes, the link to buy the
book is somewhere in the chat,
you should be able to find it.
Thank you so much for
the time that you have
to read this wonderful short story.
Thank you for answering all your questions
and thank you all for attending.
- Thank you all very much.
It's been a real pleasure.
I hope we meet in the flesh someday
and look after yourself, thank you.
- That would be with great pleasure.
Thank you very much, Ben.
Have a good night.
- Florian, thank you.
Hope we meet soon.
Take care.